you did I I love so many things you've
done one of the things I didn't expect
you to do because so many people will
dress up and pretend to be Donald Trump
you played Donald Trump on an episode of
Senate live and I have to say for
reasons I can't quite articulate I
didn't quite expect that let's take a
look at your Donald Trump really how did
it come about
okay everybody does imitations of Trump
there kate is so good like kenan
everybody does them so I was like I want
to do him but like I'm known for
terrible impressions yeah so all my
impressions sound Jamaican yeah so I
want to do I want to do Tom I think
Trump might be the one that I could do
so I was doing it in an office to Kenan
he was like yo you should gonna show
Lauren and see if he'll let you be Trump
and then you just read that's the Lord
yeah and Laura was like no actually I
know him he'd be like I love that Trump
channeling his inner sort of Jamaican
attitude I think that would be fantastic
really I don't think so I don't think so
I love it
you